All right.
Let's dig in, my friends, to the topic of
Corona virus and vitamin D. Here's why I'm
doing this today.
Medical research is looking at so many different
things when it comes to Corona virus.
Everything from testing anti-viral therapies,
looking at convalescent plasma transfusions
of antibodies.
Looking at, you know, are cases more severe
in cities with more air pollution versus cities
with less air pollution.
All of these things are being looked at and
they should be.
But when we throw a whole bunch of stuff out,
it can be hard to really think through just
one element of this.
Any of these could be fruitful in thinking
of how to treat the virus, but we really want
to dig in deeply and think through.
All of these different possibilities, so one
thing that's coming up more and more is the
connection between Corona virus deaths and
low levels of vitamin D. So let's explore
it.
Vitamin D is most importantly for for humans,
something that helps us absorb calcium, magnesium
and phosphate.
And humans can get vitamin D from the sun.
You go outside, you get it from from U.V.
light and from very few foods.
Fish is the big one.
Sometimes mushrooms, if the mushrooms have
absorbed eubie U.V. light as they were growing.
There are many countries that when you buy
milk, the milk is reinforced, supplemented
with vitamin D. Some breakfast cereals are
supplemented with vitamin D. OK.
But vitamin D has been controversial over
the years.
For a while it was very much in fashion to
do a significant supplementation of vitamin
D. Then we learn more about high vitamin D
toxicity and so we've backed off of that a
little bit.
But for a while, if you were below 30 nanograms
per milliliter, let's just call it 30.
Right.
With the exact measure doesn't doesn't matter.
But if you're below 30 in vitamin D, you were
considered to be low and should be supplementing.
More recently, 20 to 30 has sort of been considered
OK.
And a lot of people now say a lot of medical
professionals say you really only need a supplement
if you're below 20 nanograms per milliliter
of vitamin D. There's not 100 percent agreement
on that.
There is also the general idea, although the
specifics are always complicated, that low
vitamin D can increase all cause mortality.
Basically low vitamin D can make you more
predisposed to die and that you are generally
more susceptible to diseases of various types
if your vitamin D is low.
So how does this relate to coronavirus?
Well, it relates because we now have a bunch
of studies that have found correlations between
coronavirus deaths and serious cases of coronavirus
and low levels of vitamin D, particularly
with levels of vitamin D. Under-20 to some
degree, people with vitamin D between 20 and
30 and very infrequently are the deaths happening
in people with a vitamin D level above 30.
Now, right away, our critical thinking skills
should kick in and say, David, is this correlation
or is this causation?
And that's exactly the right question, because
if this is causal, it would imply that if
you take vitamin D and raise your level to
30, your odds of dying from coronavirus are
having a serious case go down dramatically.
But we don't know that.
We don't know that it is possible that the
people who died with low vitamin D died because
of some third factor that causes low vitamin
D. Let me give you an example.
If I'm suffering from severe cardiovascular
disease and I am inside a lot because my mobility
is decreased, I could have a predisposition
to die from coronavirus because of the cardiovascular
disease and I might have low vitamin D because
I'm not going outside very much because of
the cardiovascular disease.
In other words, if you have cardiovascular
disease and you take vitamin D, you might
not be protecting yourself from a coronavirus
death.
We don't know is the point.
What does the caller a scholarship say so
far?
We have a bunch of different studies we can
look at.
There's one paper called Vitamin D level of
mild and severe elderly cases have covered
19.
A preliminary report looked at 176 patients
over age 60 who had severe cobh at 19.
And indeed a lot, many of them, a lot of them
had very low vitamin D. Another study called
vitamin D deficiency as a risk factor for
severe COVA 19.
Looked at 186 patients and again, they found
that the corona virus patients had lower vitamin
D than the median population at large.
In particular, men.
So does this tell us vitamin D protects you
from Corona virus?
No, it does not.
Sadly, no.
There's also another complicating factor,
because there are studies which find that
vitamin D levels go down when the body suffers
a traumatic event, for example, a surgery.
But there is also speculation that if you
get a lung infection or lung inflammation,
that can reduce your vitamin D. So if that's
the case, Corona virus could be lowering vitamin
D levels, making the case for vitamin D being
a protective force even less clear if you
get a lung inflammation and it lowers your
vitamin D. If you then supplement vitamin
D. Does that protect you?
We just don't know.
So where do I come away with this?
Here's my perspective and it's not my opinion.
It's from what I've read from medical experts.
It seems that maintaining a vitamin D level
above 30 without going up into the toxic range
is generally a good thing.
Vitamin D is really cheap.
You can get it for free from the sun.
Taking care to protect your.
Of course, it's one of the cheapest supplements
that you can buy.
So I recently got an at home vitamin D test.
It was, you know, the end of the Boston winter.
I have not been outside as much as I'm outside
during the summer.
And my level was thirty point five just above
that minimum.
So I am not supplementing.
I eat plenty of fish.
I'm spending more time outside now.
As long as my level doesn't go super high,
there's very little risk and very little cost
to ensuring that I maintain above a 30 in
vitamin D. Seems reasonable to me.
Of course.
Always consult with your doctor.
This is a general consensus from the medical
community and not advice for any individual.
That's vitamin D and Corona virus.
By next week we may know more.